these days all Americans are told go to
college a higher education is the single
best investment but a new book the case
against education says this college push
is a big mistake how many thousands of
hours did you spend in classes studying
subjects that you never thought about
again economist Brian Kaplan says most
people who go to college
shouldn't I learned little in college I
like my friends and illegal drinking but
I slept through lectures at least
tuition then was $2,000 now it's almost
50,000 people usually just want to talk
about the tuition which is a big deal
but there's also all the years that
people spend in school when they could
have been doing something else if you
just take a look at the faces the
students it's obvious that they're bored
and people are there primarily in order
to get a good job because the diploma is
a signalling device for people with no
more brains than you have but they have
one thing you haven't got a diploma the
con man who was the Wizard of Oz hinted
at the problem years ago doctor of
psychology why'd you write this book The
Wizard of Oz already made the argument
but almost no one seems to believe it at
college graduation has never been more
valuable than it is today
education is my top priority and by
supporting this budget you'll make it
yours as well meaning taxpayers must pay
for it all the politicians say go to
college and there is evidence the higher
you go the more money you make it's
totally true that when people go and get
more and better and fancier degrees that
their income generally goes up but the
reason why this happening is not really
the college is pouring tons of job
skills into you the reason is that it's
impressive you aren't saying you
individual don't go to college you're
saying we as a country are suckers to
push it and subsidize exactly just
because it is lucrative for an
individual doesn't mean that's a good
idea for country because when most
everyone goes to college that just
raises the bar imagine that you're at a
concert everyone is sitting down and you
want to see better what can you do well
you can stand up all right and of course
then you'll see better now it does not
follow though that if everyone stands up
everyone sees better if you just block
each other's views the same thing has
happened that
education since Kaplan as more people
got degrees more employers insisted on
degrees the result isn't that graduates
get better jobs
it's that employers require degrees for
most every job there are so many jobs
where it used to be crazy to think they
would need a college degree like to be a
waiter in a fancy restaurant where now
it would be very normal of course a
college education is about more than
getting a job it's also about learning
but Kaplan says if students really
wanted to learn they would just do it if
you want to go to Princeton you don't
have to apply just move to the town and
start attending classes nobody does that
in people's bones they realize that what
really counts is that diploma today
that's a taxpayer subsidized diploma and
when you subsidize something you get
more of it more students apply to
college so schools raise tuition tuition
cost has risen a triple the rate of
inflation schools use that money to
attract more students and more tax money
many compete by advertising luxury they
promote things like lobster dinners
fancy pools students will come to us
we'd say this is what sealed the deal
used to be reading writing and
arithmetic and well we're now the 4th
our Recreation 600 colleges now have
rock walls
give our Tigers Spring Break every time
they step in to the Student Recreation
Complex this is a public school
taxpayers fund that Spring Break we also
fund years of study in subjects unlikely
to help students get jobs like social
justice Gender Studies multicultural
studies if we're doing computer science
Electrical Engineering then you probably
are actually learning a bunch of useful
skills but every year we graduate about
twice as many psychology bachelor's
degrees as we do engineering bachelor's
degrees of course there's value in
learning psychology philosophy
literature many employers say they want
liberal arts graduates
it's technology married with liberal
arts married with the humanities that
yields us the result that makes our
hearts sing it makes us better wiser
people but you can't assume that works
how many years of people's lives should
they be made to study stuff when the
odds that they'll ever appreciate it are
101 and a thousand maybe it makes our
brains work better it's the kind of
thing you'd expect teachers say but
there's a whole field of people who have
actually studied this as much as they
want to believe that you're right they
generally come away after looking at a
lot of evidence and saying wow actually
it's wishful thinking although Kaplan
calls colleges scam he says it's great
for a few people people like him I'm a
tenure professor your audience may not
realize how good of a gig this is but a
tenured professor cannot be fired for
almost any reason and you get a nice
income and there almost no demands upon
your time you just have to teach five
hours a week well there's people
consider that a horrible burden that's a
scam that we're paying so much money for
people like you to teach you five hours
yeah well I'm a whistleblower the bottom
line of the case against education
taxpayers I don't know that they're
getting ripped off government has made a
tremendous effort to make education
accessible to everyone I say really what
we need to do is to go back to a world
where college is not so accessible where
it really distinguishes you and in this
way people are going to be able to start
their lives years earlier why is this
solution all things considered would be
if government just got out it would be
good if government got out of a lot of
things